hi i'm evan carmichael and in today's
video i want to answer a question for
one of our readers james
james is a recent graduate from
university with a bachelor of commerce
degree
and he's asking if he should go and get
a job or if he should start his own
business
so whenever giving career advice i
always encourage people to
really trust in their heart and try to
follow their intuition
i can only tell you from my experience
what i did i also had a bachelor of
commerce degree from university
and i was already running my business
when i was in university
and when i was graduating i had a couple
of offers from
fairly large financial organizations and
had to make a decision
do i go take the nice high paying job or
do i
focus on my business and see if i can
make it a big success
and i was looking around and seeing what
my friends were doing and some of them
were going
off into the workforce right away i know
this were taking a year off to travel
find themselves and then get started
working
so i thought i'm going to take a year
off and i'm going to focus on my
business
and see if i can make it really take off
and be build something that i can be
proud of
and if it doesn't work out i can always
come back those opportunities will still
be there for me in a year if i wanted to
go get a job
and worst case scenario i learned a lot
about running the business and now i'm
ready to go get a job i never actually
went back to get a job because our
business did do well
so that's a success story as you get
older i think it's harder to
have the guts to go and start a business
you know once you
have a family you start establishing
roots you have a lot more commitments
it could be harder to start a business
so i encourage young people to
try to start their business as soon as
possible see if entrepreneurship is for
them
and if you take a year off to focus on
that and see if you can make a success
those other opportunities will still be
there for you a year later
if you wanted to go get a job so i hope
that helps if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up below
i'd also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
and stay tuned for the next video
you